good afternoon everyone so if you are at
the panel you probably heard some
introduction about me but before that I
really thank you for spending your
Sunday afternoon with me and trying to
learn about you know what we have done
so far in this space but as i said in
the panel my background is more on AI
and machine learning and so I ran into
Python when I had to deal with some of
the social media constructs and so here
we're going to talk about a system you
know the application of that is going to
be at a higher level this is good be
slightly different than the sessions
that you have seen so far we won't go
too deep I'll go to give some examples
of some code and so forth but I want to
talk about how what all you have learned
in the last three days how to make
business sense and business value out of
it so this experience i'm going to share
will specifically address those kind of
things so i turned this as hashtag
buddies but primarily the goal is you're
trying to find out answer this question
right so if you work in enterprises you
know a lot of times they have premium
customers so if you look at it the much
majority of the value that the company
gets is coming from those premium
premium customers so a lot of companies
that are sophisticated in terms of how
they manage data and how they understand
their customers they apply several
nuances about their customers like for
example they have knowledgeable of
business intelligence reports and so
forth to start with so that when you
walk up to a customer terminal or
whatever they know oftentimes more about
you but in the last few years that
activity has gone a little higher up so
now they apply complex machine learning
algorithms to identify for example you
know what are the preference that you
have when you do certain things they can
pinpoint to specific actions for you so
that they can send the right promotions
and they take care of your issues and so
forth but the question that a lot of my
plans ask
is all right I gotten that button down I
know my premium customers I know what I
can do for them but is that enough what
can I do with that and knowledge to do
more right and that's a quite a question
that we have so if you have been in
those kind of environments that I got my
hot personal machine learning algorithms
and whatnot and i am using that to make
somethings value for my customers what
more I can do that's a gist of what I'm
going to talk about so here we have a
notion of you know conceptually how do I
see this customer SAS so if you put the
social media interaction your customer
is the person interacting with a lot of
things right as we said earlier they are
talking to your business by making some
purchases or making something else and
they also do a similar thing with their
competitors right and they may have
other entities that they interact with
maybe some social activities and so
forth but there is a significant thing
that has changed in the last five to six
years is the social media in a great
integration or interaction so your if
your customer is interacting with your
competitors you have no information
about the data you may have your partner
data or optionally other data may be
there but now you have the opportunity
to know what they're doing through the
social media integration so what we talk
about is as a customer plus models if
you will so this kind of mimics the
concert that I talked about right so
these are the transactions that what
they do with you and here are the social
media conversations so a lot of times
when you hear the term that people build
customer models what they're talking
about is this they're talking about what
I can learn from the transactions that's
what typically people talk about as a
customer model but what we are talking
about is the next level of how you take
as a customer plus models so you think
about that here is the integration of
the conversations that people are having
right so it could be from some customers
that are outside of your customers so
how can I find more of my premium
customers can I use the social media
conversations to get there and the
answer is yes and how do you do that so
some of the adoption approaches that
works well with our customers is this
typically you do want to define you know
before you you know bringing these
methods and algorithms to yourself you
know as a business question what are my
core capabilities that I'm looking for
in my customer plus view right first of
then it can tell you whether that
information is available from either
your social media or other data and so
forth so you got have that objective
clear and much to what we learned in the
last few days you'll know that the
technologies that they're talking about
are not well proven in the sense there
are a lot of learning curve that you
need to have if you put your head in an
enterprise scenario the enterprise class
systems are not easily you know
changeable right you have your source
systems are collecting your transactions
they are very predetermined structure
and you can't change them how it what
happens and there are several layers of
transformation that happens so you have
to define that so how do you introduce
such new esoteric advanced analytics
concepts is we all know that it's very
using a proof of concept what I'm saying
is in our lot of our of enterprise-class
customers this approach seems to work so
you've defined a very small test if you
will hey I'm going to work only with the
Twitter data all I'm going to work only
with my facebook clients who have
interaction with me and so forth you
define that clearly and of course then
once again the POC then you can evaluate
did it meet my results and what are my
scalable paths so you may learn from
your POC that the sources i'm looking at
the modified chosen are not working
correctly so how to tweak something and
so what happens is you have a very
defined method of approach so this
become very important
in an enterprise-class scenario so what
do we do typically is in order for you
to go to the customer plus models what
we say is the first thing you need to
have is do I have my customer models but
it's amazing you'll find out a lot of
organizations though they have good
amount of data they probably don't have
a well button-down models of customers
they do have in pockets they know
certain things about some customers what
works but it is not a well mature so you
want to ask the question how mature is
my current customer model is all about
and then obviously you're going to talk
about social media data so you need to
have some ability to process
unstructured data that involves okay do
I have my current systems like I'm a
high only a relational databases is that
enough for me to have of the
unstructured information that I'm going
to get or do I need to have some
platforms in place and so forth and why
I'm saying all that is it takes such a
complex of steps in enterprise scenario
if you don't have all these things
nailed down in the beginning and
obviously you know somebody asked his
question earlier all right I'm I got all
the NLP stuff done correctly but my
issue is i'm not scaling so the what it
tells me is the planning wasn't done
correctly right you've got to think
about what are my scalability
requirement that i need to worry about
let's see if I'm looking at Twitter and
we know that you know the tweets are
coming in you know a millions and
millions you know so fast so we got to
figure out what I'm a strategy that I'm
going to scale is the when I define my
proof of concept am i picking the right
platforms that's going to give me
scalability am i picking the right
libraries that allow me to petition the
problem in such a way whether I do as an
application manager or developer or the
system's themselves can do when they
scale what is the fault tolerant do I
need to worry about if there is a
problem in the code do I need to worry
about fixing that as part of application
or as part of infrastructure or spotted
anything else
better you may use a third-party
libraries what is your integration
strategy right so you have to think
about all that stuff and then obviously
we will find out some examples I'll show
you that there is you know because it is
social media data there's a lot of
fuzziness about what it means what it
does not mean because even though there
are packages that implement NLP NLP is
not you know done correctly you have a
lot of context in contextual information
that is not available to the computer
that you're dealing with so you have to
expect some kind of fuzziness and so
what do I do that even if you use to NLP
algorithms you'll find out that they're
not exactly the same way and you don't
have expertise to implement the NLP
constructs yourself so you have to rely
on these additional packages so how do
you triangulate all of them to get to
the core set of information so these are
the key things that stumps when you
start to engage in this path so let's
talk about how do we build the customer
models right so I mentioned in the panel
that you know we do something called a
multi-strategy learning that's precisely
the reason why it's really complex
because if you take a look at your
regular structure transactions some have
in a categorical values right it could
be picking this product right there is
no order to it I've just like a category
right otherwise some have numerical
information there's an order to it and
there's a range to it and so forth some
may have your location information you
know it you have to put two things
together to figure out where it is and
there are other additional relationship
that can be applied to so the data comes
in several not i'm not talking about the
format but the data comes in several
formats and meaning so typically in
order for you to get the best out of
this data we do something called
multi-strategy learning what that means
is so you have your enterprise data
available in multiple types of databases
like it would be in my sequel or Oracle
teradata or what have you and then
obviously the ubiquitous access and
excel it's
amazing how many large enterprises still
do lot of work in those days right so
you have to deal with that I see some
heads nodding on the audience right and
every now and then you may have some
conversations right there may be some
customers and ovin you have your call
call center reps maybe making some notes
so that information is available five
years ago if you're built a data
warehouse you will never store these
conversations in your data warehouse you
always keep them separately right
because your systems are not geared up
to deal with that now if you're going to
try to build your customer model without
the social media with just what you have
in your enterprise now you have to deal
with that from historical perspective
you may be building a model of you know
what is my churn rate why what does my
car what do my customers do before they
leave my business if you want to find
that you need some historical analysis
done right so you have to deal with all
these kind of various you know structure
data uncirculated in different places so
you take that and apply several i just
gave you about four or five here one
talks about clustering this is about you
know i have several data points i'm
going to find out who are all you know
do similar things right it could be
saying like okay in this cluster here is
the median income or him this cluster
here is these where they live and so
forth there are some you know cluster
you form but is that enough to know more
about customers obviously not so you
apply additional algorithm like decision
trees these are you know they are called
supervised learning basically you say
for each interaction on a transaction
you say hey this is a good interaction
or this is a bad interaction or average
what have you so you have some expert
domain expert giving you some
classification of how these look like so
you run through these decision tree
algorithms they give you a decision tree
basically that says if this happens here
and if this happens here the there are
chances that
event is going to happen at this
confidence and support and what have you
so you may be able to pull some
sequential information together it's
which is very important in your own
analysis the other one is again I just
jumped into that so the situation
analysis talks about you know what time
frame you associate with that the
temporal information so that you can
predict some event based on some event
that are not directly related to that
and so you have that information now and
then obviously the neural nets are a
very unique beasts if you will basically
what it does what they do is you send
this information back is unsupervised
learning they form a decision network if
you will so that when a new information
comes along they tell what are expected
outcomes from what I see now so you form
the neural Nets so basically when you
have models from all of these four or
five machine learning paradigms you send
your any new input that is coming in to
all of these models right and they
produce results and that's what I have
understand other learned rules so what
you do is then you have a best possible
decision that you can make based on your
events now as and when more models come
into being you can integrate into this
space now the challenge is generally
each one of these results are coming in
different formats so how am I going to
triangulate that one of the things that
we do is in this particular approaches
we converted all of them into what we
call as a production who based language
evening else kind of thing but if you
look at a fair isaac or whatever they
have information coded like 'if an event
than an action and there are some
various you know you can give some
priorities and what have you so convert
all of the learned knowledge into one
centralized rule-based engine that is
your decision engine if you would so
what happens is any new information that
comes in goes into the decisioning
engine and so what happens is when you
see an event you can respond to that
this is a very sophisticated
summer model building activity and now
it is not impossible you have several
tools and available I heard someone talk
about in the lunchtime they said they
use assass a lot even the family talked
about SAS is a very powerful data mining
software and there are a lot of open
source met stuff available too so you
can create such sophisticated you know
mythology but customer so that is the
starting point for the next work so what
you do is you extend the customer models
using our hashtag buddies approach
basically I want to keep that a very
conception a very simple way you source
your conversations and organize them
right and you the way you do that is you
know i'm going to use tweets as an
example but it's applicable to many
different things you can see in tweets
you have this notion of hashtags which
the users of tweets are telling to you
that hey here is how i am viewing this
conversation as here is a clue i'm
giving to you about what I'm talking
about here is why i want your my
conversation to be associated with this
is what the twitter that the person who
is tweeting is talking to you about us
so I want to do so it's very important
to understand that and then you passes
conversations are using you know we do
we'll talk about two things so the
natural language processing and topic
modeling I kind of divided into two
that's primarily because of the tool
sets that and we're using their for the
purpose and once you have process this
conversations very it's important to
find out how I'm going to build my buddy
network that's the key part of why we're
doing all of that the goal is we would
like to form associations between
various activities and by these people
and so that I can take my customer model
into customer plus models
alright so let's get some details here
so here are putting the top here the
kind of tools that i'm using and in the
middle girl what says what the concept
is and then there are some details so to
source the tweets you know we use
twitter for j there are many ways you
can get tweets but we just think that
because you know it's not early
available and so forth and beaver you
know java focus at the time and and so
that's what we do it can't stream tweets
and there are many ways they do in the
previous version we collected all of
that into files we just moved it into
head up and went on but we are changing
that to use you know a streaming so that
directly it goes interview so that can
eliminate the disc the important thing
about all the performance thing we heard
is the less reason why you need to go to
disk the faster you're going to get and
we do some processing in that turn up rj
process you know and it's very many more
will talk about what that is but
primarily his job is to go to the API
collect the tweets this minimal
processing put it in a file and that's
it the next one is you know we would run
the tweets that we gathered through the
enough to care components right so what
I'd be doing is we will identify the
language of what it is in the Twitter
space when you open an account you tell
what language you're going to use be
using like you have the information that
really provides that I have seen some
cases where people say English is what
the language maybe something else but
there are NLP components that can you
send it to a cent a string to it it will
give you what language the string most
likely matches to its it fairly fairly
good and then we also want to extract
from the tweets the named entities these
are people person like organizations and
stuff like that that are appearing in
the text so the goal is you're trying to
find out what are my premium customers
are
interacting with or talking about right
let's say they're talking about a
particular company or a particular place
you want to know what that is so the
named entity extraction is an a concept
that identifies these information for
you and then parts of speech you want to
know the verb and all that kind of good
stuff I haven't forgot to put here but
we also find out to other things which
are expensive from a computation
perspective so we have an option to turn
on and off one is the dependency
analyzer it's so you're asking earlier
it's a tree it tells that you know what
are the grammatically what's the
structures and what the sentence is and
so that you can find out what are the
typical ways in which my customers are
talking to some organizations though we
don't do that but some organizations
actually use that to figure out how they
need to communicate with you what is the
style of speaking that you do so they
use their going into that level of
understanding about the dependency
structures and so forth so all this
computation takes a long time so what
we've done is we initially started off
with a simple you know code but then we
had to figure out a way to scale it up
so we converted into MapReduce paradigm
in this case if you look at it I get a
conversation I identify these things
right language named entities in
whatever so if you look at it everything
happens within that particular
conversation I don't have to go anywhere
else right it's all self-contained I do
load into some information right to help
me with that but that's about it so a
lot of stuff that we do in this stage we
do completely in the mappers we don't do
reduce there's much other than you know
take and storm to briefly talk about
MapReduce everybody here in this channel
what it is okay good so they help you to
scale into Hadoop space and so you know
that's what we do here from a
perspective so the next phages faces
once we have identified these
information we are taking it to the next
level right here I know what they're
talking about whom they're referencing
and what type of language
but what I still don't know is
conceptually what are they talking about
this is goes beyond sentiment analysis
so we apply a topic modeling that's this
is still a very esoteric concept
basically what his goal is when someone
writes something they have a concept in
their mind and they translate that so
there is a theory that says I can check
this collection of words try to figure
out what is the most probable thing
they're talking about so when I say
topic modeling it looks like as if it's
going to come out with a good top that
you can understand but in reality it
would be like a bag of words if you want
so now you have a summary of what
happens in this conversation that's what
we're trying to get there so basically
all these conversations we group that by
hashtag early I said that people who are
using hashtag or telling everybody that
hey I am talking about this right that
in itself gives you some idea about the
topic you take that to the next level so
we apply the LD air Gibbs sampling based
modeling we use a package called mallet
to come up with the potential topics in
that particular stage we do both mapper
and reducer so you can see that this is
a streaming part this is the first stage
of my MapReduce and that the second
stage of our MapReduce today we do that
all manually like a you know in the
script based but you know we yesterday
we heard about a system that can help
you to schedule and all that stuff but
doesn't work on Hadoop default it works
on amazon so one of those things
available you can orchestrate you know
this kind of stuff much better so in
this case one thing i do is in as i
talked about there was a lot of question
about performance right since the text
is pretty involved in the processing we
would like to apply you know i gave an
example about from a domain perspective
you know minimize the amount of
information that you're moving around
right so the mappers do the projection
of you know of these thousand columns or
thousand elements I'm looking only for
these and that way you make your stuff
very
a precise of what you are trying to do
so good question so I give an example
that you know there are billions of
tweets so what you do is when you look
for your particular search term right I
have seen anywhere from you know 150 to
700 million tweets it depends on what
you look for and and so you know a lot
of times of the you have a good
judicious use of the search terms and
that way you minimize the amount of
stuff that you want to process but half
more than half I don't have exact number
more than half the tweets are people are
trying to advertise stuff all right so
you filter as much as you can before you
get here we are not doing that in this
space there is an before I get into my
MapReduce we have a lot of cleansing
things we do and so that eliminates you
know like a bit a lot of URLs we take
all that out because they don't you just
want to know what URL is in some cases
your else might make sense but you can
you will see quickly that there is a lot
of patterns that you can eliminate and
so that way you can minimize the
workload if you're not doing that in the
beginning we were not doing that a lot
so our scalability was not as high worse
but there are some research papers
available is interesting that you know
we people use Twitter information for a
lot of stuff a lot of papers have some
information about how do you eliminate
specific things away from the tweets and
then you can clear that the other good
thing about NLT k is the taggers and all
that if you use a default tagger they're
going to tag everything one other that
may but you could train the taggers to
do certain things with Twitter for
example there is no notion of at
mentioned in English language that it's
a Twitter thing so you could create a
chunk to say okay whenever someone says
at something you treat that separately
don't do anything like you know is
trying to find what kind of tagging it
is right is looking for all possible
tags so you don't want to do that so you
can find you the tagging part of LLC
a by training that so you learn all
those things that we need to do to
before it becomes more scalable all
right so let's get them in the spirit of
this conference I have put some code in
here so what we won't go into detail but
the key thing that I'm talking about
format release perspective is that the
challenge is you have to figure out from
your conversation perspective how do i
convert that into my key value pair so
that's what this is so in my case in
this example the keys hashtag see the
point I'm trying to figure out is I'm
going to split these conversations by
hashtag right so that's my ki the
payload is you know there are many
things that I just saw in a small part
but it could be anything in my case
we've talked about the POS tagging the
dependency analyzers information and the
named entities all of that goes into my
payload which goes into that really
reduces our thing and it does what they
need to do ok so that's a simple way you
know you by thon you can write a
MapReduce code and then here is the
example of how you could deploy that let
me see if I can walk that true basically
this one is the streaming jar that you
need to provide for Hadoop to take the
mapper and reducer code into the right
notes for you so we say that what file
might contains a mapper topic the metal
code and then you declare that that's as
to be the mapper code and the same way
so the loop system will distribute this
to the several nodes and then run the
process for you ok
so here is an example of you know what
I'm talking about so this is an actual
tweet i pulled out of the system and
this is i mentioned earlier that the
twitter for Jay does that's what it
produces output ass so it basically this
is a time in which it happens and then
who did it and what actual to it is the
other thing else is that i compute
certain things about you know what it
does i think it always a place mention
or whether the profile of the twitter
has some information you know if it is
there it will say if it is not put false
or whatever so that's the kind of stuff
that it puts out okay so the key thing
they're going to working on is this
tweet form so so here is an output of
you know what happens after it went to
all the processing so the the way i've
done that is so you saw in the earlier
screen what the twitter / J component
produced so I take that and extend the
information with these things right so
convert that into database centric date
so that I can do something like that and
then it talks about you know the ad
mentions and so forth and then if there
are any hash tag in the tweets we pull
that out separately and the voice say
robbed or whatever and the this is the
original tweet but what it is and here
is the what I call a zap you is tagged
so here's how it looks like so it takes
each one of these symbols and then says
what it is like a noun phrase or verb
and all that kind of stuff okay the red
part is the output of how viewers Tiger
would look like and then here is the
dependency tree you could actually draw
a tree if you have network but it tells
that you know how what structures are
there the way the way to use that is you
are interested in let us say if you are
looking for a known grammar or a known
structure of tree that you are looking
for right we got home but this is a
conversation mapped into what it
but you have built models that you're
looking for I'm looking for this
particular tree so you superimpose the
tree that you're seeking into the tree
that it produced and there is your match
that's what you're trying to do but this
is just information and we talked about
named entity recognition this is the
name the entity face sometimes you can
see how horrible it is like the artis
organization it isn't right but that's
the I use a default cagar and so what
you do is I just want to show you is the
default tagger there are some false
positives and that's the reason why I
mentioned that no matter how perfect you
get your tagger with the Twitter space
or social media conversations you got to
be prepared for some element of you know
unclean data which i call fuzziness to
be precise ok we'll give an example of
how two different things work there ok
so once this information is available
this is what actually gets filtered and
gone into the topic conversation okay so
let me give a little better example in
terms of how the ll TK works in
sophomore right so here is another tweet
that I pulled from here so typically the
step the video that is we convert that
into tokens right it all starts with
that little piece of things that I want
to do so it'll break everything into
these tokens and then you can simply say
okay I have a past tag method available
so call that and here is my tagged
output ok so that's a plus that that's
the beauty of the NL ticket packages
where you know there you don't have to
do a lot and it is really available for
you and okay so let me go back here so
all right from this fine what I want to
show you is you know what we started off
was using Stanford NLP java-based
libraries but then we started to use you
know the out-of-the-box thing from ll TK
you can start to see the differences
here right it tagged as a person right
and here where is that
yeah nnpe so it's just that the name you
know how the terms what it uses or
slightly different right that's about it
but you can see that LAX right the NLT k
tagged as N and P but the Stanford
tagger just said I don't know you know
always I don't know me it is not taxed
so you can train this to learn those
kind of things and then you can see that
Los Angeles it identifies location
correctly I think this is the i think
it's called GPS for location start with
geopolitical event you know geo diagram
there right so that's how it tags
correctly so what you need to do is if
you want to get the best out of it you
tie your train you Tigers even then we
always prefer that if you can have
multiple passes at your data you get the
best possible answer and you mythical
your trend because you're trying to make
a decision based on these unknowns and
you would like to eliminate as much of
unknowns as possible and that's the
reason why we believe in the multi
strategy based learning of running this
in two different ways okay so once we
have done with that we you know with
that once you have that kind of detailed
yet available you run through the next
stage of process where you run through
the topic associations right so I got
the topic model and build and obviously
the way the topic model works is it
takes the conversation and let us say if
i say i'm asking the topic modeler to
find out at most 10 different topics all
right and it's going to find out 10
topics because i said so and it's gonna
assign a score to this conversation okay
this conversation has 0 point ninety
percent association to this particular
topic and 82 this and what not so you
order that and figure out what is my top
ten percent of that so you can see a lot
of uncertainty and fuzziness is getting
built into the system right so that's
the challenge and then once you're done
with that high-ranking information you
have you know person too
person and here is what they talked
about and so forth you start to build a
buddy network so we use Python network
x4 that there was a question about the
scalability yes certainly does not scale
very well but the way we did is we had
multiple networks of independent
networks and so our goal is you can have
a hierarchy of networks those things can
be are possible and then you can run a
different set of algorithms on different
layers off within the network and so we
use networks to do that and once we have
the network structure formed you could
derive lot of associations let me see if
I can show an example here so here is
how the beginning of the end body
network looks like say for example what
it says is this person is tight or
associated with this person based on
what they're talking about you know like
gardener and bread whatever and then
they also use this is the topic so this
is the hashtag and there's a number here
at eight what that is is there is a I
just have an internal ocean ocean for
the topics and so it says that this
first these two relationships are based
on the two names of people and then lets
you and then the hashtag and then within
the hashtag what topic it is so let us
say if this person happens to be your
premium customer and if this person is
not right now you have an opportunity to
reach out if you have the way to engage
with them on social media so that the
key part is is about engaging through
the social media you just can't do
anything else that's the best you got
and that's the kind of information they
finally get with this okay
alright so this network is a very small
part I've pulled together I have seen as
high as nodes like you know 10,000 loads
and lot of relationships and so forth so
you married that to the transactional
behavior that the customers are already
explained already have done performed
for you so coming back to the first few
question that we asked right by now I
hope you know if you believe that the
answers that I have or these you know I
think it made sense you know here is
what we thinking about the key part here
is you have to set some metric right how
do I know did I get the right person
because answer that you're getting from
most data mining applications are it's a
probable answer i'm trying to find
pattern matching we think this was going
to happen but it's never always true so
you gotta set what are my measurement
targets I've been in some industries in
the past where when we do this kind of
models we set a specific test model in
mission on most machine learning things
you have a test sample you use what you
learn from the test sample on your other
samples and then you can deploy that
into your production systems okay
believe that that's it any question
yes that was the goal because you don't
have any information about right you
don't have any information about you
know let's say this person is not your
customer you don't have any other
information right so you could you know
that's the one and in social media if
you have the twitter handle you can you
know if you may be able to reach out to
them it's just one example I'm just
wondering how customers react being
reached out to you know that's actually
it's a very good point you know you're
right the the governance in all that is
very important right we never ever want
to say here is just go why would they
don't do that so if you have a proper
governance what happens is you are
reaching out for a person if you know
for sure that a service is required and
if there is an engagement I'm not
talking about a selling process that is
about an engagement process you're
engaging with the customer you're not
blindly saying hey you know if you have
my airline customer here is a freak you
blow right that's that is your right as
creepy you're wondering like how do i
know i'm going to go to this place right
here you start engaging process
differently a lot of companies are
trying to specifically address that
through change management and so forth
so this has to be very carefully
orchestrated you're right you don't want
to use this information to reach out you
know whomever you want to
so there are suggestions that come out
here it will get another copy does it
somebody they got from the Felicity that
we have you get this they keep coming
it happens at gmail it happens with
Yahoo everywhere right everyone is
trying to figure out and a little is a
personal observation what I do typically
is and browsers are very careful about
closing down the browser before I go to
the next one and i think you know there
are a lot of things that happen in the
browser level itself without having to
do you look at your tweets and whatnot
but this is in a very responsible way
we're talking about to engaging with the
customer you're right this is not to say
you know here is how you can do what you
need to do we are talking about a
premium customer because you do want to
make sure that you may be able to reach
your premium customer you may be able to
reach this person using your opinion
customer you don't know that right so
there are so many ways and cuz the
conversations are actually thinking
about how to do that better so they
understand the creepiness of the social
media interactions right yes
the leap the target customers for this
application would be any any enterprise
that has a loyalty program that could be
a line or retail what have you so in the
look at the airline you know you have
your purchase airline tickets and so
forth and you have clickstream analysis
they say for example before i bought
this ticket well at all they clicked you
know what is a path and so you have
information about how they got where
they got so those are the transactions
that they have there's nothing to the
social media but does unstructured but
it is the transaction that they have
that's for the earlier example on retail
of course you know market basket right
with you what all the things that you
buy becomes your market basket so you
know what you do and so far very good so
what happens is you know a lot of times
when the company is engaged they have
information about your email account on
your twitter ID these are all
voluntarily people share so that's why
you find out you know I don't know in
some cases they ask if you want to mail
your email receipt to you an email right
so there are ways in which this
information is found and also there are
some companies that will triangulate
many information into that yes
yep yes right now we with our next thing
is about using images right so we have
some image processing algorithms to you
know find similarity but you know we
haven't exactly laid the road map out
but basically what we're thinking is
anything that has a topic you know right
now we're doing a conversation so and so
you know using hashtag as an example but
eventually you'd be mapped to a concept
from anywhere else on me tubs I have 15
people sign up yes I found only for show
up but there is no data within it show
up like I
like 500 people who like the top eight
when you are the fundraiser to show up
or just a false predicament I am looking
for a pressure cooker and because of
cost and I I see above Kabam so whatever
the wrong predictions and the falls
analysis where is the loop being
connected for the feedback to make
accurate predictions okay so that's a
good question there's always in these
things this is a false positive we are
very careful about you are identifying
hey I can apply this the scenario but it
is incorrect identification so in
organizations whenever they apply these
there is always a measurement of what is
my you know there is a set of measures
like you know recall and then how many
hits I have and so there's a measurement
of saying if I'm making this prediction
or projection or recommendation what is
the next event that happens to that that
that tells you whether are they
responding to your suggestion I am
making or not and then you use that the
pattern to tweak your models because
that's what i said in the beginning when
we deploy this we always start with a
small test sample and then you perfect
your model because of this being a pure
prediction there is no right or wrong
answer in a lot of cases but if you if
you send this kind of information to
let's say you know twenty percent only
responded that tells you your model
SCORM you're scoring not the conclusions
but you're storing scoring the models
lot of times organizations have multiple
models they are testing and so then you
fine-tune and you know make the models a
little bit better and that's the reason
why you want to check your expectations
coming out of the proof of concepts and
so forth
okay all right
all right thank you guys appreciate it